so yeah i mean now that [ __ ]
lockdown's been
happening again i guess we can call it
the 17th time for the 17th time
i don't know lockdown in japan has been
weird right it's a rollercoaster it goes
like the cases go up they announce a
shitty lockdown that's like two more
rules added
and then the case is good now and then
and then they go back up again when they
let go of restrictions
and then this is happening like the
fourth time now yeah so we're just doing
the same [ __ ] over and over again
but this lockdown is the shortest ever
it's only two weeks or something yeah i
think
what's to change in two weeks i think
they literally just wanted to be like oh
golden week's happening
uh let's let's let's have it not happen
meanwhile i'll explain
everybody to the viewers who don't know
yeah so golden week is this week uh
during the first week of may
uh where as we're recording this we're
in the middle of it right now where it's
basically just a bunch of public
holidays
back to back to back to back-to-back so
i think yeah so
basically people just get a week off do
you know how i remember golden week
it was the one week of the year aside
from like new year's where manga
mangakaz would take a break from that
weekend so i'm just like oh one piece is
on break
what the [ __ ] golden week thank god
finally
everything's on fire i didn't get one
piece this week
that's the only reason i knew of golden
week before moving to japan
yeah exactly well because like i think
you know japan needs golden week because
yeah japan is one of the few countries
that works on christmas
you know like christmas is just like i
think everywhere else christmas is like
a public holiday or at least like
in australia well yeah like in australia
like you know
it's like the second half of december
yeah until maybe the first week of
january like three weeks it's just yeah
full on holiday christmas here is just
valentine's day 2.0
yeah it is it really is [ __ ] yeah but
they were just like
i don't have a cup i don't have a
partner finna work
it's either you're on a date or you are
working on
something yeah exactly so i guess like
you know to japan they need golden week
because it's the one time where they're
almost forced to take the week off yeah
because otherwise they get
i mean you know people still are just
like no [ __ ] it it's still working week
for me but
yeah yeah my whole favorite thing of uh
all the japanese government's lockdowns
is that they did
in the in like during the whole pandemic
the government thought of this amazing
idea called go to
travel she's just like oh yeah this is
just the funniest
this is the funniest [ __ ] thing so
japanese government they were losing a
lot of money obviously
from tourism that they wouldn't they
weren't getting so in the middle of like
the pandemic this is like months ago
it's before this is last year was during
the first lockdown wasn't it
yeah yeah they were like guys we're
losing too much money in our travel
economy we put some money back into it
what we're gonna do is guys we're gonna
give you
30 off everything and we're going to pay
you money to go travel
we'll give you 200 bucks to spend
depending on how much you spend and uh
yeah you get coupons
yeah yeah yeah so yeah they were like oh
yes so like
it's a lockdown but also if you travel
discount hey there's some money to spend
go treat yourself
king but don't leave the house though
but don't leave like yeah and then like
they realized it was like a colossal
mistake like a month later when
the cases went up i [ __ ] up because
everyone's of course everyone's gonna
travel
exactly you're paying me to travel and
you don't want me to travel
like if you went to like a five-star
hotel that's like a thousand bucks it
would go down to like 600 and then you'd
be given like 300 bucks to spend and
it's like
who isn't gonna do that like if you have
disposable income anyone is going to do
that it's like dangling a carrot in
front of a horse and telling the horse
not to run right
don't don't i'm finna i'm finna try to
be responsible yeah yeah
japanese governor making me act up you
know what i mean i want you know
i was like well [ __ ] i'm going hokkaido
everyone abused the [ __ ] out of that
system right everyone went traveling
yeah because
it was like why wouldn't i i went to
like four different places i was like
i'm obviously not because like literally
everybody is going right so it's like
what's the point what's the point of
knock going it was the most confusing
period ever because they were like don't
travel but please travel
please please travel we need it for you
and then and then they shut it down like
after
like a month yeah yeah of course it was
it was a colossal mistake
i mean i went to hokkaido because i was
like [ __ ] yeah you know
i didn't interact with anyone but i
think all three of us went to hokkaido
different times
i went way after and it was because it
was because you guys kept talking about
hokkaido and i was like okay
i think it's my time to go to hokkaido
as well waited for lockdown to end and
i'm just like damn this is
they they weren't joking around [ __ ]
hokkaido exactly
exactly in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere
no one's there it's like great yeah it's
peaceful it's fantastic it was just the
dumbest thing ever because if they
just kept like this is the whole thing
that the japanese governments are doing
where they just kind of haven't really
committed to anything
yeah they haven't really told you not to
do anything i i think i very wish you
were
i think that's the thing every every
restriction they've given it seems very
half-assed from my
like from my perspective no it's it's
not it's not been like
we've never been fully open but we've
also never been fully closed either
like they've never said you can't travel
around they they're
the worst things oh if anything they
reward you for it yeah yeah yeah and
then
no and then they also said like oh yeah
you know restaurants please close at
eight
you know like suddenly for some reason
people are just you know magically stop
getting infected before right yeah i
mean this new lockdown there were like
restaurants can't serve alcohol anymore
right yeah and i'm just like
so i'm still allowed to go to the right
yeah yeah yeah
but i just can't drink beer like it's
it's generous to even call it like half
measures it's like
you know like a quarter of measures yeah
is what they do and
you know i don't know i don't really
care about the whole politics at all but
i wish they would just decide what they
wanted well that's the problem isn't it
is that like unlike a lot of countries
the japanese
japanese law they can't force
establishments to close down yeah like a
lot of other countries
and so they're like they're like okay so
we can't force you to close down but we
we
we advise you to not serve alcohol to
not
to close after eight but there's but
there's also like
from what i heard there's like a penalty
for like establishments that
don't follow those rules you gotta find
a [ __ ] ton of money yeah yeah the
restaurants that make so much money
that's the thing i would just pay the
bills the penalty is so low that there
are a lot of restaurants out there
especially in like in a tokyo that are
just like
all people yeah some of like the biggest
restaurants i think just pay the fine
yeah they pay the funds but they make
more off of the money that they yeah
yeah yeah and also they were like the
biggest that was like not even the fine
it was like we'll put you on a list
of companies that stayed open and
obviously to a lot of japanese people
that's like that's pretty like [ __ ]
we'll go [ __ ] we're gonna be on the list
yeah but then for some of them they are
like i'll [ __ ] give a [ __ ] about it
it's like getting on the naughty list on
santa right yeah yeah
it's like oh no that's so so dumb yeah
so dumb that's the thing it would have
this would have
been at least australia in new zealand
like totally locked down
yeah like new zealand were like no yeah
yeah australia no one could do anything
australia locked down for like nine
months
yeah yeah and like people couldn't go
outside for more than an hour a day and
like yeah
all restaurants were closed all that
kind of stuff and like
yeah and then when in sydney at least we
got one case
and the entire city went into lockdown
for like a month yeah
meanwhile japan is like a thousand cases
don't drink at restaurants
it's like cool thanks